[Music]
you have a perfume it's available
commercially yes some things have
changed as we last saw each other yeah
you come in with a perfume I've been
wanting to come out with a men's scent
and no one seems to want to market it it
smells like cinnamon and desperation is
fine this is billionaire boyfriend is
your scent oh yes this is the second one
yeah there's boyfriend then there's
billionaire boyfriend okay and and he
may interest you to know that they cover
two totally different effective
categories and it's I don't know how
you're supposed to do this and then walk
through it right yeah I'll do it towards
the camera you know getting your eyes in
your mouth you wanted sort of like spray
it and then walk into it like that
looking like this I've put a lot of this
stuff on yeah yeah it's really gonna
come home my wife's gonna say you're
having an affair wow I really overdid it
I apologize
I think it's drifting its way towards
the crowd now and they're trying to pass
out good lord no no this is real this
this whole thing is going to smell like
this for a long time
you do really fun ads for for a
billionaire boyfriend yeah it was
there's an ad campaign you did one where
you play a Bond girl yeah you saw your
tape right yeah by the way I also fight
you look amazing in this app but let's
let's take a look at that I think it's
fun
[Music]
some girls will go to any desk for their
boy
I have only one criticism you're gonna
get a fan correction about the octopus
that's possibly the worst looking
octopus
[Laughter]
[Music]
the octopus is like that's Kate Walsh in
a bikini we there's a lot of struggle
that all I knew is I wanted to wrestle
an octopus I was like I don't know let's
make it a perfume where I can wrestle an
octopus so it was it was I just had this
ridiculous that would look and we
couldn't get the thing to submerge it
was bad enough to try to get it through
customs like this octopus became the
bane of our existence in the end it
looks kind of funny that is that is
waiting for we couldn't sink it we had
like eight people to wait for it is you
know metal why I can tell it's under
water against its will that's my
favorite now speak of getting killed you
are leaving private practice do you know
if they're gonna what they're going to
do to your character are they are they
going to kill off oh I don't know what
they're gonna do but I was like I kind
of want to go out in a blaze of glory
like literally like just just run out of
a building on fire completely I don't
know something really dramatic dramatic
dramatic but I don't know if that's
gonna happen choke on a chicken bone
while on fire I'll be the bear you're on
fire you pause eat a chicken sandwich
spray the perfume watch through